how do you use a color palette is there
a rule as to how much of each color to
use there is a rule in fact but rules
are also meant to be broken but let's
start with the rule so here I'll show
you 60 30 10 they equal 100% so
essentially this is kind of like the
baseline color ratio that I would
probably start with so the 60 percent is
obviously the color that will be used
the most 60 would be like your primary
color so this is like your hero the 30%
is your secondary color it's used about
half as much but you know it's still
fairly visible and then the 10% that's
the accent color that's that's kind of
like your little wild card where you see
this work really well is in web design
so maybe your background could be the
secondary color if you want it light
right this kind of life right here and
then maybe your headers are blue or
something right and then where you might
use your accent color this little 10% is
maybe in calls to action so like on a
button or on something that pops up like
things that you really want to get
people's attention and you want them to
look at that's where you would use that
that little 10% yeah accent color a lot
of times you'll have kind of different
types of the same color and I like to
keep them in in the same kind of ratio
so let's say you have like I like blue
with dark blue you know there's like
it's kind of really light color then
there's like a brown or a tan then you
have a couple different shades of the
accent color just to kind of expand the
palette a bit
I still like to keep them grouped by
ratio so I sort of put all the cool
colors over here in the blue and then
even though this is kind of creamy it's
it's like it's still warm
so I pair it round together and then a
few the two purples are the accent over
here so that's a very quick baseline for
just taking all your colors and trying
to like try to basically just ration
them in a way that that makes sense if
you enjoyed this video then you're
really going to like my
course that's right I teach a course
it's called color for creatives then we
go over color theory how to pair colors
together and I'll walk you through my
whole process for building palettes and
then using it in my illustration work
it's pretty neat
visit the futurecom slash color and
learn more about it
[Music]